if we can get along anybody can
Amen to that love building a bridge
ladies don't you think it's time the
headlines are kind of shocking Naomi
excludes her daughters from her will but
ET obtained the docs they show neither
Wynonna nor Ashley was appointed
executor of Naomi's estate estimated to
be worth 25 million dollars instead she
left husband of 33 years Larry
Strickland in charge I knew how fragile
she was let's talk about what a salty
single mama she was
she could be evil
Naomi was of sound mind when she signed
the will in 2017 giving Larry full
Authority and discretion to live in or
sell any of her properties including her
family farm without the approval of any
beneficiary I love having my land that's
the most important thing for me is my
land and this is where I live Naomi
showed off her Nashville area home to
Oprah's cameras it's where she died this
past April and her 1 000 acre estate
includes both daughters properties
Ashley he said this is my happy place
she said as long as you guys are right
here
this is my favorite place in the world
do you find it hard to have boundaries
on the compound when you have your mama
lives next door over here oh we have
boundaries she lives next door you do
we're very clear with each other we
visited Winona's home there last year
and while her rep didn't respond to ET
about a report claiming she's upset
about the will it's important to note
Naomi's daughters could be named as
beneficiaries in her trust and either
way neither is Cash strapped combined
they're worth an estimated 26 million
and both seem tight with their stepdad
Pop I love you we've we've been through
a lot together I've loved you since I
was 15. speaking of financial support
Tyler Perry is revealing he paid more
than a million dollars to another Legend
we lost Cicely Tyson don't get me to
talking about Tyler she said I helped
Revitalize her career after Diary of a
Mad Black Woman blew my mind the two
worked together on several films Tyler
even named a sound stage at his Atlanta
Studios after Miss Dyson but now Tyler
tells AARP the Magazine's August
September issue he actually took care
year of Tyson for the last 15 years of
her life including hiring her for the
sequel to Why did I get married and I
prayed for a miracle quote she did one
day of work I paid her a million dollars
it makes me feel great that I was in a
position to give this incredible woman
some security in her latter years a man
who came from such lonely States and is
taking with him everyone
should be lauded